Chúng ta có thể đánh ai
Chào dừng giống như không
Con sĩ nó về chào
Con tất cả bố tất cả các cuộc đời
Bố chào
Chị sợ vơi như nó mà
Này thơ thử
Về hơi nơi tình
Con lẽ có thể bố em
Về hơi như nó
Về hơi như nó mà
Về hơi như
Về hơi như nó
Con sĩ thơ
Về hơi như nó mà
Về hơi như nó
Anh hết nửa s
20 năm tuổi
Quên nình bình
Không mai bị tên nạn sợ thông trong buổi tối cuối cùng của năm 2018
Là con chai cả trong dài điện có bác người con
Anh là chục của chính lo cho dài điện
Bởi chai bị mất một chân cách để hơn 30 năm
Mẹ anh không được nhìn nhẹ
Chai nhẹ nhẹ nhẹ nhau chia sẻ
Tên nạn sĩ ra quá được một
Ông móc mình có thể làm gì đó
Thế phần anh để anh được sống như không thể
Nen nói đau
Dên anh cứ đỉnh hính tảng con chai
Mà lại hi vọng sống cho những bệnh như suy tạm dài đoạn cuối
Trong lỗi nước mắt thuộc cùng
Dên đa lựa trọn mỗi cái cửa đẹp để sự sống được tiếp nối
Để yếu thương không dừng lại ở chili và tự đỏ tình người Lan Phóa
Cậu đồng cùng nắm tay nhau
Sự ấm những trái tình đang sử dụng tổ thường
Xin cuối đầu chiên dạ điện người hính tạm